ces lacunes c'est d'abord les trois
tâches de son appareil industriel
c'est incontestable l'allemagne n'a pas
la voiture pour être une puissance
mondiale
ils demandent notamment le pétrole mais
surtout la main d'oeuvre pour pouvoir
concurrencer des géants comme les états
unis l'empiré britannique où l'union où
l'union soviétique c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est la
faiblesse de son appareil logistique
rentrer en russie avec avec un des
unités qui sont largement hippomobile
c'est peut-être ce n'était pas forcément
la meilleure chose à faire
il ya aussi bon mobile les jeux jouets
tractée par les jeux tractés par des
chevaux de classe a dit oui
effectivement c'est quand même c'est
quand même un petit peu juste
il y à aussi fondamentalement comme le
fait que la la les chefs de l'armée
allemande sont investissent énormément
le côté opérationnel c'est à dire ils
mènent des batailles pour ce que la
guerre ça se gagne mécaniquement en
menant des batailles en accumulant les
victoires mais ça ne dispense pas d'une
bonne stratégie
or la stratégie allemande est en vérité
une véritable catastrophe
et enfin ce qui leur a manqué c'est
aussi des alliés des alliés fiables
les alliances de l'allemagne en dehors
du japon mais qui est une alliance qui
ne va porter les fruits que 13 heures
directement et de façon très lointaine
les alliés de l'allemagne ne sont pas
faits pour une guerre moderne ni la
hongrie ni la roumanie ni ni l'italie ne
sont des alliés qui font qu'ils vont
tenir le choc long très longtemps
l'italie va même devenir un véritable
fardeau pour la stratégie allemande dès
même les finlandais dont on a célébré à
l'envi le courage sont en réalité dans
une situation de stand by à partir de la
fin 1941 et n'apporteront pas non plus
aux allemands le soulagement qu'ils
espéraient
[Musique]